my dad was a builder and I spent most of
my childhood on different construction
sites surrounded by the sounds of power
tools so the thought of making music out
of all of these nostalgic sounds
combined with your clear interest of all
the comments asking me to do this
naturally I had to accept the challenge
so it is highly unconventional idea I
contacted my good friends at Rio B who
sent me all of these power tools if you
come around the back here I've connected
each two to the central switchboard and
a mic up and all ran into this loop
pedal which is connected to my interface
that's simply recorded to my laptop this
is what each item on this rig sounds
like nail gun drill leaf blur angle
grinder chainsaw compressor drink saw a
pressure gun planar poor Japanese
pastries
I've added in three wildcard instruments
the first being these two recorders
connected to this high-pressure gun my
Korg synth and a kick drum now the only
question is what kind of song darling
but first this video is sponsored by
epidemic sound the music platform for
creators that I've been working with to
give you all the knives sounds for you
can use in your videos but more on that
later I know I'm sorry dad this is the
most random question I'm busy shooting a
video but what nursery rhymes that I
listen to as a kid on a house it mark
what is the first nursery rhyme that
pops into your head
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
whoo so I guess that concludes this one
way to piss off your neighbors so just
before we enter for the seeing sounds
it's been it's been a blast it's really
been awesome I love making these I just
want to talk a little bit more about
epidemics and for those of you who don't
know what epidemics aren't is epidemics
and is a royalty-free music platform
with incredible music I make use of I
mean if you watch my other vlogs and the
folks that I make most of the music I
use comes from the epidemic sites it's
incredible because you can download the
stems and I mean I can think about how
much more you can do with all that stuff
in later videos the exciting thing is is
all of the sounds that I've created for
these seeing sounds are going to be
available on the epidemic site I know
they were supposed to be available now
but as you know how we do things it has
to be done properly and in the timeframe
there was just so much so many sounds as
you can imagine so we've extended it out
by one man I'm sorry for that but please
look forward to that because there is so
much rad [ __ ] on the way and all
downloadable for you yeah if you haven't
already check out epidemics and I'm
gonna link them in the top link of the
description and then yes please I love
the comments keep them coming please
keep giving me ideas of things to make
as you can see there are no limits
I will quite literally do anything
anything and other than that don't
forget your awesome brew and I'll see
you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]